gioiese questa volta non ci sono casi io
vinco per l'ultima frase non ci sono
casi le mie ex hanno già chiuso il video
ma voi no perché siete persone perbene
world
cerchiamo di capire dove ci piazza a
caso nel mondo 3 2 1 per giappone così
perché me la sento
tensione quanto agli guardali madonna
rare a chi mangia di geografia ne fece
un confronto vero sia giapponese non
creano sono già aveva di merda comunque
ore ma zuma sua ma non so leggere ma su
sacchi area cucù l'uomo mi guardava
giappone sicuro ragazzi secondo me siamo
nei pressi di chi ho sposato osaka usata
su un cavo uno dei due metri che non ha
azzeccato ma la linea rete incredibile
ero a matsuzaki e va bene anche o meno
ragazzi che tra cinque giorni sono qua
playnext round by ma siamo sulla rotaia
di un treno ecco mi ha piazzato un
header in questo momento qua a questo
punto spiegami perché tra tutti i punti
proprio su una rotaia ed un treno crono
guard questo sicuramente norvegia fermi
tutti e norvegia comunque quasi
sicuramente se non norvegia sarà il
momento di svizzera a caso in mezzo
madonna col propongono al caso milian
credibile ragazzo limitano al fenomeno
associato per aver seriamente pian piano
sto imparando la geografia questa roba
già assurdo ecco come hanno detto che
cazzo si sa ci è mai passato un nuovo in
questo punto
as roma in canada non raga incredibile
non ho mai visto una cosa del genere
cos'è secondo me se vado avanti non
trovo un cartellone anche tra dodici
chilometri però canada per non saper né
leggere né scrivere canada
qui ora ga porca eva era in alaska
maracas ci sono andò vicinissimo ogni
volta ma son diventato rete un genio
cielo alla ca nun ce ne sta diventando
un fenomeno in alaska è però più o meno
dext round che è il credo di sì che sono
le case del film di jane mani di forbice
case negli stati uniti tutta la vita
però non capisco salde signore possono
sbirciare il barbecue delle altre
persone fantasmi gaga che fantasia ste
casertano dal 108 di blu da qualche
parli cadute rosa è sta roba
ho finalmente una casa diversa qualcuno
che mi fa una barca cosa strani in
catene fargli una barca in un posto così
spiega ragazzi non ho veramente ideali
dove potrà prima stracittadina reame
interpreta mamma mia la città è più
brutto all'america ma mortorio almaguer
e gunma mortorio veramente sto posto
facciamo qui c'è giorno idea è in
florida a napoli napoli c'è una città
che si chiama napoli in florida ma mi
state prendendo per il culo ma veramente
vabbè napoli va bene non capisco ma ok
ecco c'è un signore con trattore che
sicuramente saprà dirci non ci si pone
anche andare lì figurati se questa
invece ragazzi se non e in finlandia lo
butto musi proprio perché la finlandia
mista noi norvegia norvegia mai così in
turchia traiano del matto ragazzi prione
un'altra facciamo tipo cos'è sta roba
inver clive deamer clyde bello a devi
indovinare i posti senza muovermi e che
queste carina eh vabbè mi piaccia o no
come fa ma anche quanti piccioni quanti
piccioni ci sono salve buongiorno mini
spot ed perche femminili what
ma senza muoversi raga impulsive e bello
il fatto che non ti puoi muovere ma
barcellona barcellona barcellona loro
letto la l'autobus mica un fenomeno
barcellona qui era due chilometri di
vista se io me ne vado mai a era classe
de catalunya traduce acquistato capirla
quasi alcune lardo rock mi sia stato
1600 volte come fate a non riconoscerla
subito dai ragazzi next round senza
muoversi sempre questo è semplice no non
è vero un esempio avevo visto una ruota
ho detto cosa da london eye non è london
eye è un paese orientale quasi quasi
quasi quasi la butto su cina ma non gli
è proprio di dover più brutta qui a caso
proprio già giappone gioco a mano lavori
mai detto amiche non sembrano giappone
giro va bene extra large ore la pace
corso sempione l'anno e milano e roma e
milano sul caso cioè in testa questo la
mamma gli ha detto lava i piatti te con
questo gli è rimasto in testa va bene
anche lui l'altra mamma una fantasia
incredibile a me lo fate le foto in hd
porca [ __ ] non si vede niente
se c'è scritto in via c'è scritto libia
sono in india perché mai ci dovrebbe
essere scritto india va bene lo so
comunque un bye ma non penso sia mumbai
sta roba facciamo la kfor dove che era a
nuova band che mi chiamò a essere
anch'io sono un deficiente porca vacca
come ho fatto a un potere lunga l'india
a face rogazzo mica finalmente o il
colosseo erano una vita non usciva
almeno 13
non pagate il bene almeno uno santo gesù
continua a sbagliare ponte non lo trovo
aiuto eccolo e non riuscivo a trovarlo
vabbè io non riesco a picchiare il punto
preciso spot ed quindi qua tipo genio
grazie gesù grazie alla regina
d'inghilterra che ha permesso tutto
questo e faccio fare faccio anche le
belle figure nei video fantastico il
test dell'idiota e abbiamo detto sono
semplici queste a eb e forse anche
qualcosa tipo che si mette lì a
censurare tutte le facce che era nottura
di palle giorno signora bel balcone ha
prezzo vediamo quanta gente sta facendo
la foto con la torre di pisa pecora
sapevo movimenti neonazisti a pisa
guardali seguaci di hitler non ml in
groppa un bel vecchietto rialzi da
dietro mi sa che questo lo sa solo
questo mi sa che poi vinti rivestono
tira bene se mi chiama mi fa fare la
precisione perché minchia queste via
roma o via di sta minchia che vi è
sembrato nello loro saremmo
no era la quarta porta benefica si va
bene anche a 200 metri contento prossimo
arrivo postale credo sia il miglior ne
sono sigma tomac e sbatti censurare
tutti che rotture di palle cedesse
veramente assurdo italia italia come a
caso nove ragazze guai credo sia a new
york non sono sicuro dato non so neanche
dopo il mandato che figos opposto carati
qui si mischia chiarissimo ve lo giuro a
caso un misto a caso due giuro
l'ho messo completamente a casa non
avevo idea va bene così questo e nello
spazio è la madame cosa estero come
sopra monte carlo sembra montecarlo ciao
ciao ciao ciao poveri ciao poveri
montecarlo yacht e ibiza olio vco
guardato questo questo ho detto mica
sembrano un de carlo non l'avevo letto
qua ma mai nella vita c'è ma ci sono
stato una settimana fa a montecarlo
madonna un fenomeno era conferenza non
ha un certo però fa quando nel genio del
cazzo cosa va mai cazzola lesbica
dovrebbe essere in teoria tenendo conto
dello svincolo mica se ci ha detto no
500 metri dove a borca con sto guardando
dall'altra parte di pirlo vabbè dai
peccato comunque 500 metri va bene le
sembra il caso
ti sembra il caso ma io non mi ricordavo
tutte ste macchina al louvre ma io mi
ricordo neanche di una rotonda louvre un
cazzo è possibile scusate ma sarà anche
sono scemo io ma numerica
comunque pazienza parigi michel il
budget delle toilette dove a questa è
bambi 38 mentre di vista sbaglio sempre
punto proprio a questo a casa mia bel
orami chiaramente i segnali in un po
dietro siamo a posto
ciao frate riquadro che se volete io so
come dentro la casa bianca che ne so io
conosco so penso gravame altro tipo
l'hanno fatto entrare per quale motivo è
la casa di donald trump e che bello o
ashita no farò un'altra volta e farci
una figura di merda washington non è lì
e dall'altra parte porca vacca the white
house e voi anche la stanza voi perché
c'è la planimetria della casa bianca ma
state male cazzo ne so io qua sei metri
vabbè dai mi chiamo non è che vada
stringe la mano a tramp e parchi a tema
nel mondo ed è la madonna che cos'è il
parco della ferrari questo già visionato
salwa non è in spagna come che cazzo ci
è arrivata da subito non so se la spagna
e credo sia a barcellona ma guarda abu
dhabi era ad abu dhabi il parco della
ferrari ah beh allora si è allora syfy
capisco grazie mille gentilizio ciao
neanche quelli che sono sopra salvatore
sono ma ti pare che dimentico ma che
cazzo fai le foto così anche questo
italiano così far mentre fa le foto poi
guarda al telefono tra ma boh non lo so
era messico nella merda era uno dei
perchè potevo attaccare e l'ho sbagliato
porca vacca non ci posso credere
veramente sbagliato
ballando è il nostro parco divertimenti
bellissimo giuro che non ha visto un
parco divertimenti più bello di questo
giurano ha subito ci vado qui c'azzecca
belli parking lituania europa park sono
quello poteva giocare lo sbagliato
[ __ ] mia sorella per chernobyl dentro
chernobyl
va bene cosa mi chiami rappresenta
chernobyl sul serio non so dove sia
chernobyl non ne ho idea
stiamo qua no era nei paesi badoglio del
tomorrowland ma cosa caccia parco
divertimenti c'era una cratere di una
centrale nucleare come cazzo è possibile
che sia un parco divertimenti il parco
recapiti di fallout ragazzi spero che vi
sia piaciuto non me ne intendo di parchi
divertimenti rimediamo rimediamo adesso
che i giapponesi andiamo in due o tre
vediamo di rimediare un po come sempre
un momento che mi piace anche vari
giorni ha cominciato da tiziana sociali
si scateni ci picchiamo il prossimo
video beh ragazzi
[Musica]